welcome to this video one playing ads at
Stan eat off ok we have a Queens gambit
let's the Netherlands right yes yeah the
small flag sometimes and not completely
conclusive so I've got a Queens gambit
this is one of the guys wear and have a
100-percent score two games two wins
sounds good so let's keep it simple and
take their Bishop d3 is also not a bad
move and 0 with the Queen I should have
at least them well but should be three
was kind of almost pre-move and I should
have given this a little bit of thought
ok you can check me on before now yeah I
think I have to King yeah 92 Queen g2 is
awkward ok so if he takes on d3 i'll get
my piece is coordinated quite quite well
this one ok it's important I cannot go e
for he will take that with the Queen so
let's take and play for Queen d3 may be
here
if he takes on FYI think I'll take a six
it could be an interesting choice the
night is a pretty decent piece in this
position I think do I get to prevent him
from playing civ 5 that would be really
nice if i manage that i don't see how my
king is in the center that can actually
be an advantage here for me and some
kind of end games if you go see 5 know
what is that f5 wow that's surprising
okay absolutely okay hmm didn't expect
any of those moves but f-for is not bad
getting that in quickly it's not a bad
idea okay Brooks is 6 blocking c5 hmm
it's not quite clear how however using
this the bishop only success is just
covering c7 very reliably my knight can
come around 12 to a check to check your
fire maybe hmm okay I'm doing that but
i'm unsure about the about the pure
quality of the move so over there my
king is playing that's important
so he wants to double on the e-file
maybe ok where ID is 90 to be 1c three
you see what this does he have any kind
of idea here Bishop f4 right that is a
move well I doesn't move
I don't like to play g3 that seems
somewhat wrong if I go back with my rock
VLC five that's something that I also
don't like to see ya should afford our
mats it's kind of annoying okay probably
after
still want to go night be 1 93 and then
attack d 5 or plane I'd be five that
takes a long time though so I've got my
doubts maybe it's got something
interesting that you can do I would to
see you want to join them might get a
Droog f3 on that more I'm not sure what
g5 is about or maybe he just wants to
fix my pawns on dark squares it's
possible but he didn't do anything about
this idea and this looks awkward we
cannot move the bishop and c7 has
attacked I me can move the bishop but
this looks awkward yeah I can takes his
seven now black resign Charlotte that
wins the house I don't know it was a
difficult position um I wasn't one
really sure my whole plan I mean it was
very slow he didn't do anything to
prevent it and but I think he probably
was able to so maybe if we look at the
opening briefly here after this check
yeah I played Bishop d3 essentially like
a pre move because I was just thinking
about it takes but 25 is actually a
normal move there that is the displayed
um yeah he now went here and kini too I
don't think that this is bad for me
because he loses time with that bishop
and the king is not so bad on e2 I think
that this is kind of an okay okay I
could have taken c7 but I never really
looked at this and I wanted to get some
harmony in my position and not grab
pawns even though the engine is
mercilessly taking it and gives me plus
one
maybe maybe it's not quite clear what my
problem is here the engine wants to do
this and then John gets into this
position the idea I'm yeah this is just
a point Black has no compensation yeah
maybe I could have taken but ok I I
wanted to have control in this pollution
and here i thought that this should be
kind of interesting with this play here
on the sea fowl the engine Oh ever gives
queen bee three and I don't have a good
reply to that huh okay I wasn't sure if
I should go with the h ro Corsi rook and
then I just played Roxy one okay see one
queen bee three though as possible I
have no good way to cover it the
computer has this line which is not
exactly brilliant and and have very I
have some vague compensation against
those pawns but it's not great you went
with this so ever and yeah yeah it
should be definitely okay it just I
shouldn't be better and some are turned
out that that I had an advantage so I
made all the moves that you have to play
okay i can go here for here which is a
simple way to just have an equal
position but i wanted to try to attack
the d5 pawn with that maneuver them okay
and the engine gives night age four year
that is a move I did consider actually
but I wasn't sure where it leads to
after after this computer however and
points out g4 and this is indeed
interesting interesting idea I don't
think that this is bad g3 here in a 92
and now he here he has to do something I
mean I have an idea
and he just didn't didn't do anything g5
and don't know if you want this is
difficult now okay the engine says I'm
winning now yeah I was thinking no not
that I'm winning but that he should do
something against this idea it was I
thought them strategically rather
obvious that i wanted to regroup the
night to attack here but he never did
anything against that even this was an
ignoring stuff idea where I'm just I'm
just totally totally winning yeah I
don't know he simply never did anything
against my plan and he certainly could
have played the autumn defensive move
just to prevent it being so one yet so
awful it was funny as all night moves
here from here 123456 and then it was
the end of this Bishop quite nice okay
thanks for watching